every morning Sunil Kumar shows up for a
job that few anywhere would want to do
as a manual scavenger he cleans block
drains and gutters in Dennis Sunil has
been doing this for six years he earns
anywhere between 400 to 800 rupees a day
that's about five to ten euros you
almost threw up the first day here until
then I've never cleaned the toilet in my
own home the stench was disgusting
I nearly quit but I had to feed my two
children since I'd lost another job so I
carried on the work is extremely
dangerous there's no machinery or safety
equipment sometimes so needless to
undress and squeeze into the sewers to
unplug them
he says he's developed skin allergies
his eyes burn from the toxic gases the
labourers belonged to the balm icky
community that sits at the bottom of
India's caste system their work opens
them to prejudice and discrimination
some people treat us as if we're not
human
we're human too now you're sitting here
it's very dirty but people cover their
noses when they walk past why is that
manual scavenging was outlawed in India
more than two decades ago the law
prescribes fines and even jail time for
those employing workers to manually
clean toilets sewage systems and septic
tanks without protective gear but the
rules are routinely flouted with
devastating consequences
this settlement on the outskirts of
Delhi is home to Dalits
formerly known as Untouchables two
months ago three of its residents choked
to death in a septic tank in a car parts
factory
all three were cleaners none had safety
equipment one of them was nanny his wife
Poonam is still waiting for compensation
for the company my children don't
understand that their father is not
coming back
our world has come crashing down I've
had to borrow a lot of money since I
lost my husband and I don't know how I'm
going to pay it back
the issue has sparked an outcry reports
in the Indian media say more than 10
sewage workers have died in Delhi alone
in recent months the city government has
since banned its agencies from
outsourcing sanitation work to
contractors who hire manual scavengers
Ashish Keeton
a spokesman for the Delhi government
says manual scavenging has no place in
modern India but he admits the rot runs
much deeper
it's absolutely inhuman its medieval
there is a problem of lack of awareness
there is problem of insensitivity and
just callous attitude on the part of not
just the police but I am afraid large
sections of our society because they
don't see it as a as wrong as as a moral
wrong as a legal wrong that means little
- Sunil and his friends they finished
here
they're already off to the next job
regardless of the law they will always
be enough demand for cheap labor to do
the city's dirty work